[Music]
Dear Santa as the time for gift giving
and Goodwill draws near I know exactly
what I'd like to receive this year I
want a nice video that when I hit play
will make me feel like it's Christmas
all day everyone uses the same ulog Loop
they think it's Charming but I think
it's not very good I want something
replete with holiday Splendor please
tell your elves time for a new Christmas
render Nico
and welcome to the 2022 Christmas render
challenge I've enlisted our best VFX
artist elves to create Christmas themed
satisfying cozy renders and then gift to
Nico he deserves some presents I would
say he deserves such a good boy yeah
we're gonna give it to him good yeah elf
style elf style you know one of these
little renders we're going to create
today will be his favorite we will be
pouring ourselves into these in the
hopes that this good little boy will
think that we're the best little elf so
Jalen here's the kicker the worst little
elf will be downsized to the South Pole
and the three hour timer Starts Now
so I have an idea for render that I
thought would be really fun Santa has a
little accident one where he gets thrown
from his sleigh and jammed in a chimney
my program of choice for this is Houdini
although I've never used this for
anything that was like fast-paced I feel
very good about my decision so far gosh
darn it it just started we're literally
30 seconds it already froze that's
content baby good Lord I'm gonna reboot
it
it's a bad start
it's a bad start and any minute now
this will work okay let's see uh come
back to me baby
I'm gonna need a Christmas miracle
we're back
they're they're excited stylistically I
want to aim between realism with also
miniature photography like a snow globe
it's a little bit ambitious given the
time but I'm confident that we can get
it done I bought a little elf pack which
would just came with like a little posed
elf I use him for all the elves because
they all look the same just look at me
and Peter I got a sleigh too I think I
spent about twenty dollars
where did Santa come from who is he
really topics like that will be explored
in my render I found a free model of
Santa on the internet all I had to do
was just quickly re-rig it for unreal so
yeah I do need a little rigging help
weight manager weight manager oh yeah oh
my God now don't ever say he should
manage his wave okay
we're not talking about his
weight control a and change this from
absolute to smooth and then apply all
perfect totally I promise this will be a
flattering rendering of you if you know
your santalore there's a little Valley
up in the North Pole called Murder
Valley it's the only way to get to
Santa's house that is what I'm trying to
recreate Jesus Christ Sam's making a
[ __ ] videos
that's amazing
I've done a lot of violent CGI I kind of
would like to Rebrand you know I want to
make some cute CGI it's going to be a
cute little critter sitting in a blanket
with another cute little critter if
they're snuggling in front of a fire
they're having a great time and adorable
thank you I just dropped some dollars on
uh guinea pig a Dachshund and a cat I
paid at least thirty dollars you spent
30 bucks at least I'm all about bang for
buck the 20 bucks that I spent oh that
went a long way tremendous bang in that
buck Peter though how much bang did you
get
a significant amount of banks
significant amount of bang sounds like a
lot of bang I didn't spend anything
the cheapest what I am trying to achieve
with the surrender Daniel is the feeling
of a cozy Canadian Christmas morning the
Vancouver Canucks are playing the
Toronto Maple Leafs and everyone's just
gathered around the fire they're eating
some delicious gingerbread cookies and
some hot cocoa just enjoying those
Christmas Vibes I'm going for like Lo-Fi
Christmas Vibes yeah Lo-Fi Christmas
Vibes to study to or just in general to
Christmas too yeah that's true all right
little elves two and a half hours left I
can't believe all this time has gone by
already I'm kind of kind of freaking out
man I don't know if I'm going to be able
to achieve all of my wildest dreams
in this short amount of time I'm not
trying to win I'm just trying to make
sure he doesn't win you know you see I
don't have pointy ears you don't know
why
Jordan Allen came with his Clippers he
thought it'd be funny I could hear us
whoa he keeps saying it's a prank but
it's a prank that only I was in on yeah
I think he did it on purpose
all right everyone while the elves are
hard at work downstairs I decided to
sneak up here and tell you about today's
sponsor Bessie besties are my favorite
gifts to give during the Christmas time
and I'm going to tell you why when I'm
Santa I'm not out here giving gifts I'm
on all these rooftops there's snow
there's dirt there's sleet well guess
what vessies are 100 waterproof and snow
proof so my feet are completely dry the
whole time no matter what situation I'm
in also I'll let you in a little secret
it doesn't snow everywhere for
everybody's Christmas sometimes it's
dirty sometimes it's actually super hot
of course it snows a lot of places so
the padded Diamond text material is a
dual climate knit which keeps your feet
cool in the summer and warm in the
winter it's perfect for what I do the
best part is you just pop them off you
hose them down outside leave them out
for a little bit and they're good to go
like brand new it's completely dry it's
the best all-around shoe not to mention
the lightweight comfortable breathable
they're basically like wearing socks
what more could you ask for investing
even has beanies to keep you warm they
got waterproof hats to keep the Sun out
of your face if you're all swimming they
even got gloves I mean this is like
Santa's Workshop dream I mean I got them
down there knitting them in works shop
right now they're really the best
Christmas present you can get so if you
would like to get some go to vesti.com
Corridor crew for 15 off everything site
wide perfect holiday gift get as many
shoes you want get them for your whole
family 15 if you go to bestie.com
Corridor crew you won't regret it now
let's go check on those vendors there is
one hour until we have to render I've
built out my scene for the most part
I've positioned the geometry that I
needed to position for the snow and all
that stuff I'm actually going to build a
very simple snow system inside of
Houdini Houdini's so freaking fast with
this stuff you're talking hundreds of
thousands of particles here and it's
like it's no big deal at all which just
still to this day blows my mind tis
magic indeed wanna see some dope watch
this little snow
levels shitloads of snow what do you
think the North Pole looks like oh it's
no way baby those snow particles no you
better not crash something you [ __ ]
assistant
this is bad yes it helps me tremendously
this is what I need I got this giant
pre-made beautiful map but
it's too dense I'm gonna just rebuild
this whole environment from scratch one
hour left I just had a genius idea
satellite height map data from the real
North Pole
I can make this
completely authentic experience where is
Santa's Workshop the United States
Postal Service recommends we send mail
to Santa's Workshop 1225 reindeer Road
North Pole Alaska with this satellite
data I won't have to rebuild my
environments from scratch in fact
knowing that it is authentic I think
they'll add to it you know hey there's
murder Valley just like the storybooks
it's incredible it's real oh here we are
get ready because it is gonna get so
[ __ ] Merry we got our first crash of
the day to be fair I was being hard on
blender I was asking it to do cloth
simulation using the sculpt brush using
collisions and on a bunch of different
objects so I don't blame it only half an
hour left so with these last 30 minutes
I'm going to be adding the sauce we've
all seen a nice render but what makes us
go wow is the sauce is the little
details here and there where it's like
oh my God they added that oh my God they
added that so I'm gonna be drizzling
some sauce onto the kitchen board 30
minutes left uh
feeling a little crunched I'm trying to
get to a point where I can have a fully
rendered scene because from there
I might be pulling out a little secret
weapon it's called stable diffusion [ __ ]
the sound of some cozy boys having a
great time on Christmas
what's your favorite part about
Christmas the spirit of giving how lame
is that what the heck but I'm serious
it's nice why what's yours honestly it's
snow going back seeing family getting a
face full of snow oh boom no no
seriously dude that's that's what it's
all about my favorite thing about
Christmas time is seeing my family get
together we usually drink a lot actually
it's great my favorite thing about
Christmas is just the Good Vibes you
know everyone's having a good time no
one's stressed out everyone's just
feeling content I love the Cozy Vibes
with the fam and the friends
gosh darn it this thing froze come on go
go go go go go I'm trying to render out
just one single frame so I can start
tweaking a nuke and for some reason it
does not want to do it I'm going to hard
reset it when did I save last
we'll be back we're back
over to me there
they hook me up brother
I'm gonna spend my last five minutes
just making this hard as Frick I think
that's the best use of my time just
polishing this thing in calm because I
think that's where I can really get the
you know cozy Vibes to really come
through uh my ambient occlusion pass
isn't working for some reason so I might
have to just go without it I don't know
why that didn't work no more ambient
occlusion it doesn't work
oh I gotta crash
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine no
oh no you [ __ ] oh he crashed two minute
warning
I got a snack Eater over here oh you're
crazy he's eating snacks I'm sure
flexing on them haters I don't have a
home button how do I Snap the ground
quickly dog
end but I don't have an end I don't have
it it's not a real I need to get a real
keyboard
it's so hard to turn off the nitpick
those big old pointy years of yours
failing you I smell your snack and it's
making me so hungry
there's 30 seconds maybe you could have
a snack finish your Dawn render it stay
right here
okay okay
we got to do one thing that's really
important two one hands up
all right we're bringing in the pack of
nose these kids are getting shipped off
you know that feeling when you don't
blink for three hours
foreign
all right so it is Christmas Day and the
word around the North Pole Nico is that
you are the best good boy around here we
wanted to see if we can give you a new
updated Yule Log to play at your
family's Christmas wow the thing is you
have to decide who made the best one
wait I thought where this was like a
team effort we're like we all work at
the same Workshop one of us has to go
man one of us has to go it's the only
way where else does an elf find work
other than the North Pole I guess you
make those little crackers little
cheeseburgers I'm touched that you guys
won't go through all this effort just
for me it's more for keeping my job yeah
but bring us the first render again
this is from Fenner
that is cozies
I know you like AI so try to use as much
as possible for this what's AI in this
is that the log textures it's all the
textures
it's all stable diffusion took my
blender render did an image to image
stable diffusion reprojected all those
textures and did a really nice job so it
gets all this really nice like kind of
tune shading detail you even have like
different like glossiness for like the
table different materials
oh my god oh that's a good idea yeah
that's good genius a crazy never before
seen workflow at the same time done
during a render challenge oh amazing
let's see what the next elf has to offer
my liege this one is from John
thank you hey is this like polar bear or
what is
we don't talk about that before you open
your render I would just like to say you
have been such a lovely boy this year
yeah and so I wanted to give you
hey I wanted to give you a gift what
else nose is red not brown bro and I
want to give you a yule log that will
not only satisfy you but satisfy the
entire family delightful let's check it
out
foreign
[Music]
because clearly he biffed it and this is
uh also utilizing mixed frame rates you
know I saw Dean and Fenner do it
beautifully for the spider-verse and I
thought you know what let's get those
elves claymation Style no motion blur
animated on twos and keep the snow on
ones for that smooth Christmas feel do I
see some wiggle bones happening on those
hats an extra bone for these owls a lot
of people don't know but our head
continues into the Hat it's really weird
the snow was created that's a full
particle system it's very well art
directed and it's got this insane
organic feel to it looks like actual
true claymation yeah not showing me in
the best light but it looks beautiful is
there a way I could just play this on my
TV for like 10 hours straight you could
this is perfectly looping very
impressive very cozy Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas can I keep my job we'll
see we have to get to the rest okay
is there any chance we all keep our jobs
today is that on the table I think that
is on the table but
Elvish friends bring forth your gift
there you go from Peter France oh my
goodness
wow that's cozy
oh dang I love the bokeh you son of a
[ __ ] you went for that asset
he's so stinking
okay
I I couldn't scrub through the fire
asset in blender so so it's kind of a
fire hazard but you know it's an open
concept fireplace
oh I spent about 45 dollars on assets
honestly to me it's Priceless
it's gonna be tough the top but let's
see what's next
I heard uh you're you're a gamer you're
into archery I am you know I tried to
integrate all that into a cozy cozy ass
[ __ ] record for you
Nico may I present to you
your cozy render well I'm chilly you
might not realize it but there's
actually a story here oh yeah you made
this in a couple hours yeah yeah
so you can walk into the render oh you
want control you want to be Santa I do
so you're Santa you gotta collect your
mail the children's mail it's in town
this way it's treacherous along the path
are all the enemies of Christmas
well there they are get them get them
[Music]
just a heads up you can't die
so you made it to town you win
that one's like a full experience look
these are all incredible renders World
building and storytelling and
composition they're not just technically
impressive they're like through and
through impressive so they're going to
be one winner and it's so hard to choose
but obviously it's Sam
sorry about yours I'll kill you but no
no it's okay guys
yeah Jenna told me you all get to keep
your jobs
Christmas is safe because who just wants
one present for Christmas I got four and
they're all amazing and they're all
special and they're all gonna actually
be playing on my TV for real with my
family this Christmas if you'd like the
10 hour Loops of these satisfying Riders
on your TV well there's a playlist
coming up here in a second with the
annotations in my link in the
description below merry Christmas
everybody happy Holidays happy new year
thanks so much for joining us this year
can't wait for next year it's gonna be
awesome and uh yeah go enjoy some time
with your loved ones Merry Christmas